have you ever gotten excited about a new
champion that will definitely be broken
have you ever recommended a build to
your friends that's guaranteed to do
tons of damage through his gameplay
driven can dish out tons of damage and
dominate a game have you ever lost your
mind over League of Legends biggest
plays if you answered yes to even one of
these and you probably know AB David
freaked early freak is one of the game's
longest serving casters and has grown
tremendously along with League of
Legends but in a lot of ways he stayed
true to his roots whether you started
watching him in 2011 I'm David freaked
early I'm joined here with Joe Miller
hello hello or 2019 massive brownie
points we can take down liquor we'll see
who can there's 5 and 0 so far but not 0
5 and golden Guardian so for more on his
verse victory of the year Avila is
standing by with the golden Guardians
midlaner his love for the game has
always been a driving force for the
scene this is his story
tons of damage in the beginning freak
was just a kid who loved video games but
his first foray into competitive games
came in Warcraft 3 freak had a knack for
Warcraft and played the game
semi-professionally and as he improved
he found himself with an urge to teach
others how to get better I first got
into casting when I was maybe 10 or 12
or something my first sort of
inspiration what I wanted to do in life
was something more kin the teaching that
I wanted to sort of share my knowledge
or excitement or love or whatever in the
early to mid 2000s there was no such
thing as YouTube and sharing commentary
on a game was a lot harder than it is
today so the only way free could share
his content was to upload replays along
with a corresponding mp3 file and so my
first order for unicasting was was more
in replay commentaries they you know in
modern day turned his bhadra views but
back in the day you know you'd like zip
up a replay and an mp3 file and upload
to a fan site and it was more about
teaching people to game this led to all
kinds of creative techniques for syncing
a listeners audio and video files from
the traditional but I am at the
one-minute mark of the 1x feed from
Lin's point of view you should be as
well to the less conventional hello
hello hello hello hello oh damn
I just sang It's Raining Men rap style
oh I one minute mark let's unpause this
if you're not the one-minute mark well
turn back this is audio about a man and
a half and listen to my ride again as a
teenager freak work for fan sites like
WC replays and wc3 addicts while
competing in high-level Warcraft
tournaments on the side he's like a bye
baby on look towards the end of the
decade freak was on a Warcraft 3 team
that was managed in part by a young
Christopher Montecristo Michaelis that
led freak to become friends with Monty's
college roommate
David Byronic hero Dunn who had earned
an internship with an up-and-coming game
developer called Riot Games
Byronic hero told freek that he should
apply and so with almost nothing on his
resume except four years of Warcraft 3
content freek managed to land an
interview with the company
needless to say freek got the job and
among his responsibilities was the now
iconic champion spotlight videos a
prisoner turned revolutionary stylist is
ready to seize the enemy's power then
break the limit hearing freaks voice
explained champion mechanics in highly
produced videos from riot is something
that fans in 2019 have become accustomed
to but they didn't always look that way
hello welcome to the Ezreal champion
spotlight presented by Riot Games in
this video we'll be discussing items
runes and masteries as well as some fun
tricks that Israel can pull off in the
beginning freek did every aspect of the
champion spotlight videos himself from
recording the audio and gameplay to
editing the video the champion spotlight
videos ramped up in a big way in 2011
and into 2012 as Freaks voice became the
official first look at gameplay for new
champions nocturnes passive is Umbra
blades every few seconds doctrines basic
attack will deal bonus damage splash and
heal himself based on the number of
enemies hit and they made a lot of
champions in those years
releasing 24 in 2011 and 19 in 2012
welcome to the League of Legends
champion spotlight featuring cabal card
the twisted treant vein the night hunter
hecarim
the shadow of war kha'zix the void river
and of course they became iconic enough
to spoof in a memorable April Fool's
video I start the game at level 18
because I'm Lee sin the blind mug the
champion spotlights were also where free
coined his most recognizable catchphrase
I've al Korean which gives me a trinity
force charge and I deal a ton of damage
in addition to dealing tons of damage
with his abilities dealing tons of
damage to feel a ton of damage tons of
damage
tons of damaged tons of damage and deal
tons of damage with buckshot tons of
damage the line was so memorable that
riot immortalized it in-game as freak
was cementing himself in the community
he was also becoming one of competitive
league of legends of leading voices
hello everybody and welcome to the
League of Legends League of Legends my
own game I can't say it right League of
Legends season $100,000 championship the
global finals I'm David freaked early
I'm joined here with Joe Miller it was
very early in league's competitive
history when riot decided to wrap up
their first season of competitive play
with a world championship in John
shipping Sweden at Dreamhack the events
production was so rudimentary that many
fans affectionately joked it was taking
place in freak spaceman still as fnatic
triumphed as shushei posed with an
unnecessarily open shirt freek was there
he provided commentary and helped
decipher a still developing game for an
increasingly large audience in those
early days it became clear that freaks
great commentary was in part due to the
fact that he was very good at League of
Legends it was obvious that he loved the
game but he also played it at a
relatively high level placing highly on
the solo queue ladder in both seasons 1
& 2 and in season 2 league's fledgling
eSports scene began to explode
it's the biggest league of legends event
yet the best players from around the
globe are competing for the biggest
prize pool in the history of eSports
announcing the season 2 world
championship
the 2012 tournament circuit that led up
to the world championship saw League of
Legends grow in popularity and caliber
of play and all along freak was there
providing analysis and commentary
sprinkled with some really questionable
puns oh it's going to be massive but of
course these teams still allowed to get
their own sponsorships and kind of a
crew further inked up but just just
pretend that you know season 3 is like
you got a Philosopher's Stone of a heart
of gold you can still farm it it's just
fine that's kind of how the system's
going to work which I know that everyone
likes and I understand that and I'm
sorry for home to the wrong way but
honestly I'm kind of a point where
people are going to make choices that
will not be for everyone I don't think
you could you can perform and I think
casting is a performance you can be
those popular singer in the world people
will dislike your music and when the
year culminated in a world championship
that was nothing like the scene had ever
seen freak was there too she's into it
also super awesome because it was
transitioning and one of the first
eSports events that went from being at a
general gaming convention or our generic
convention and just overall to here as a
venue just for this tournament and it
was a super cool experience though the
season 2 championship saw the scene grow
beyond anything anyone could have
predicted it was about to get a whole
lot bigger
when freek was first approached by riot
about creating a North American League
for the game in mid to late 2012 he was
unsure of its potential my first
reaction when I heard about LCS which
started in 2013 I heard about it in mid
2012 late 2012 my first thought was that
wasn't going to work not that it
couldn't work but it wasn't going to
work yet like I thought 2013 was too
soon and that would that was my thought
maybe not all the players or all the
orbs were maybe ready or something like
that and and maybe you know people
weren't weren't quite ready for what LCS
was but it overall it became something
awesome the game was still relatively
new and there had never been organized
leaves in eSports on the scale of what
riot envisioned but with the risk came
an opportunity to make eSports his
full-time job and he ran with it it
didn't take much time for freek to
become a fixture on the North American
broadcast as both someone with great
game knowledge and yes more puns so
freak how are you enjoying the European
side of the LCS well shocks calling
McDonald's because I'm loving it
yeah I really happen all right quick
shot let's take a look at yesterday's
games and as the LCS grew freaks casting
evolves over time he distinguished
himself with a style of play by play
that was more analytical than some of
his counterparts certainly I think every
caster has their own style and unplayed
plays I am arguably the most different
unlike other play-by-play casters who
excel at hyping up a situation
[Applause]
freak brings a style that allows him to
play off his color caster while helping
the viewer to dissect the mayhem that
takes place in a professional league of
legends match Walter becomes a jointed
lamination the flash engaged the black
shield is on a massive stun comes
through a special low on health healed
himself up odwin chases down sneaky
focus to kill wild turtle
goes down to media's it special goes
down as well the repel in the air 8 3 4
0 on this engage a broadcast with freak
on the mic means a deft mixture of
analysis with the color caster sharp
teamfight calls and of course the odd
punt
alright I'm calling him for some backup
freak where yeah sorry I read freak is
not here call me earthquake today cuz
I'm aftershocks and though freak is now
a polished caster it didn't come to him
right away he had to learn to balance
the puns with the hype to read the room
and give the audience the reactions they
craved
oh yeah the big driver for me when I'm
when I'm casting is to be honest to what
the game or the event or whatever it is
right if it's opening day of the new
season it's it's a big moment and it's a
very serious moment okay something funny
happens yes can make a joke but but
people are on the edge of their seat
because they want to know who team look
of risk cloud9 with the new rosters
Jensen versus gold and glue or or NIST
skier whoever replaces him right that's
a big deal if you're game 1 of the World
Finals I throw on the edge of their seat
and every single thing matters if you're
a week 7 of the summer split and clutch
gaming are just intent and they can't
make playoffs ok their teams don't mean
as much and and so that that really
influences how I cover stuff if I'm
casting worlds there's a lot less jokes
because the games are more important
it's easy to see growth in some of
eSports earliest voices but freak is one
of the scenes best examples of keeping
the heart humor and passion of the
scenes grassroots days while merging it
with the polish and flair of modern
casting at one place that polish and
flair shine has always been the LCS
where iconic moments in North America's
increasingly large domestic league have
often been brought to the masses by
freak steady voice wildturtle got to be
locked up two kills make that four kills
make that almost everyone going down
cloud9
cut the Serie
they're gonna take down the Nexus and
they're the North American champions
double-o Media Center Menachem traces
white button down below
SGA
[Applause]
three if that goes down 40s down the
next this open there is no defense
Spence Garrett shows up but the base
will fall
[Applause]
with America but of course modern
casting shines the brightest on the
game's biggest stage from the first
world championship in 2011 to the most
recent one in Korea freek has been the
voice of some of the game's most
memorable moments it's on the game's
biggest stages where riot usually
employs a try cast format that freak
doesn't need to go back and forth with
his colour caster and he gets in some
ways to be that 10 or 12 year old kid
again
the one who loves games and wants to
bring that love to the world and not a
single champion can stop them fanatic
with a 3-0 run in the semi the first
ever world champion hopes to be the
latest it was always interesting as
play-by-play because you you kind of
when you think the game is going to end
and the team is pushing for the base you
have to start your call because you
don't want to sort of sit there hemming
and hawing like Oh will they won't they
and then hit Nexus and you're like will
they won't they then the end and you're
like what other crowds cheering said
shut up
and so you need to project a bit early
and in this case in game 3 fnatic I
think could have won the game and chose
to go back for a baron or reset okay so
I had two M game calls I had an end game
call where I'm pretty sure they could've
won the game and it was like okay
they're gonna turn around and Haven out
okay nevermind North America will not
stand in their way
Korea has not stood in their way and
they will apparently have to wait for a
bit longer to see them victus as well
what I kind of liked about that was
though that was certainly a little bit
awkward I think both were good calls I
had important things to bring out there
was enough story to the match that that
either one would have worked in
isolation and would have felt like a
first choice and so that was just sort
of a nice thing for me that that I had
sort of enough ready that has for the
moment okay c9 300 or party fnatic Rio
okay well they're the best in the West
like they own the crown Europe goes you
know this is their year they're into the
finals that's super awesome fnatic you
know back to their season 1 title and
everything else
so yeah overall I thought just there was
a lot on sort of a tactical level that
went really well that's not my final and
the last hope for the West will be
fnatic that came to the west big kings
of Europe it's going to be fnatic look
at a knock it down to the five feet
three to get those last few kills a
desperate engage and has shut down on
the cap a few more second spot but look
at the blade color it's everyone dead
fnatic are that came to the west and
they will represent in the world final
and from the hype to the momentous it
was also freaks play-by-play that
ushered the world into a new era of
international league of legends
[Applause]
Samsung Galaxy their 2017
champion today freak is one of the
longest-serving casters in league of
legends but his role in the community
has changed over time perhaps into one
that the kid who wanted to be a teacher
would be most proud of freak has grown
into a sort of elder statesman for the
scene and true to his roots he's put a
lot of effort into educating the
community his voice still appears on
every champion spotlight the righteous
shall prevail welcome to the kale
champion spotlight team but he's also
taken to breaking down meta swings on
his YouTube show freakshow welcome back
to another episode of the freakshow
it is the freakiest time of year and
that means worlds is in full swing and
I'm gonna celebrate that by taking you
on a magical journey through the world's
2018 meta games specifically I want to
talk about three champions who may have
given eSports fans a jump-scare
and streams intermittently usually doing
an exhaustive breakdown of every patch
let's talk about patch 9.5 I quite like
this patch I think there's a lot of good
changes in it there's always gonna be
naysayers you're like why didn't you do
X if I don't think it's a good patch
perhaps one memorable example of that
roll in the scene was freaks feud with
Tyler won in 2016
Tyler was not really that much of a
personality though like is it nobody in
his only marketable skills being an
[ __ ] plagued no mana you have no mana
[ __ ]
they've since reconciled to some degree
even playing together in a show match at
the NA LCS summer finals in 2018 I
walked into the room I've never seen a
man so gorgeous
a man so well bald yeah and I looked at
myself when I we had something in common
exactly my forehead is so shiny you're
looking at a mirror that gorgeous man
was you and though Tyler one is far from
the person freak picked a fight with
years ago the memory of their beef has
definitely stunk
well so if you go back and watch it we
played Yasuo mmm then irelia and then
Katarina a one on Yasuo
yeah lost honor Elia hmm and I won on
Katarina mm-hmm do you follow
that's a two-to-one victory but where's
the mana now 32 Freak has come a long
way from the days where he fell in love
with competitive games and dreamed of
sharing that love with the world he's
seen scenes rise and fall and been at
the forefront of arguably the biggest
eSport ever he's taken that love that
passion and that humor and brought it to
the masses he's gone from the corner of
a convention center to center stage and
through it all he has remained uniquely
himself freak has ridden the highs and
the lows of this wild eSports dream with
much of the same vibe that made many of
us fall in love in the first place
freak doesn't come across as the
successful celebrity in a burgeoning
industry that he is he still likes to
make awkward jokes and play and shout
about the games he loves when you watch
freak cast or stream it's easy to feel
like you're part of something big but
also something that's just a lot of fun
in a lot of ways that's what's special
about eSports and it's also what's
special about freak
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]